voilà quoi ressemble souvent les rivages
du Nord-Est d'Hawaii au large le vortex
de déchets du Pacifique Nord un immense
continent de plastique flottant il
déversent sa pollution quand les vents
sont forts l'océanographe québécoises
Sarah Jane Royer villaba depuis 15 ans
on a découvert que il y a de 75 à 86 %
des plastiques qui se retrouvent dans
cet océan de plastique qui provient d'un
des filets de pêche des bouées des mono
filaments de nylan qui sont retenus par
les bouées à la surface de l'eau elle
participe aux discussions de Paris cette
semaine avec l'organisation au Chine
clean up pour qui est le militent c'est
grâce à leur travail que la question de
la pêche y est abordée
Ocean clean up est à l'origine de
plusieurs systèmes imaginés pour retirer
le plastique des milieux aquatiques
selon l'OCDE il y aurait aujourd'hui 30
millions de tonnes de plastique
accumulés dans les mains et océans et
109 millions de tonnes dans les fleuves
et rivières
attends regarde les chiffres il y a un
camion de poubelle
rempli de plastique à chaque minute qui
se fait déverser au niveau de l'océan de
l'environnement une menace pour de
nombreux espèces et aussi pour le climat
parce que la très grande majorité des
plastiques sont fabriqués à partir du
pétrole et le plastique en général une
fois qui est sous les rayons lumineux il
va avoir une photo dégradation qui qui
va relâcher des gaz à effet de serre
donc en fait la pollution par le
plastique et les changements climatiques
sont les deux les deux problèmes
environnementaux les plus gros au monde
le plastique serait responsable de 3,4%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sur la planète nous nous sommes donnés
collectivement deux ans pour avoir une
entente internationale légalement
contraignante le ministre Steven gilbaud
suit de près les pour parler de Paris
une étape importante dit-il vers
l'objectif ambitieux d'éliminer toute
pollution plastique pour 2040 parce que
le présentement recycle à peu près 9 %
des plastiques alors c'est beaucoup trop
faible comme comme taux de recyclage on
veut atteindre au moins 80% dans les
années à venir mais nous aurons aussi
beaucoup de produits de remplacement
certains de ces produits là sont plus
biodégradables que d'autres alors il va
falloir effectivement investir beaucoup
en recherche et développement les
recherches de sarajean Royer viennent
d'ailleurs de démontrer que les bio
plastiques avec lesquels sont fabriqués
certains sacs ou certains verres ne sont
pas biodégradables en dehors de l'usine
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire qu'on achète des bioplastiques il
y avait 0,5 de désintégration de
dégradation après plus d'un an
d'incubation dans l'eau de mer on
devrait vraiment se focaliser sur des
produits que l'on va utiliser à long
terme le Canada a récemment banni six
plastique à usage unique dont les sacs
d'épicerie les
ustensiles et les pailles dans cette
lutte environnementale planétaire c'est
un tout petit pas dans un marathon et la
course s'annonce difficile la production
mondiale de plastique a doublé en 20 ans
et si rien n'est fait ces déchets
pourraient quadrupler d'ici 2050 ici
Jean-Sébastien culty Radio-Canada
Montréal